und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend österreich hat gewählt und die
rechnung von sebastian kurz ist
aufgegangen
er hatte am ende auf neuwahlen gesetzt
als das berüchtigte video aus ibiza dies
oft nicht vom damaligen fpö chef strache
die rechtsnationale partei in einen
strudel stürzte da hinein wollte der
junge kanzler seinen partnern ganz
gewiss nicht folgen
er setzte darauf dass er im wahlkampf
zur zuflucht der konservativen werden
könnte
das ergebnis heute gibt ihm recht er
kann seine partner jetzt wählen und
schließt nichts aus auch nicht die fpö
wolf christian ullrich berichtet aus
wien
[Applaus]
dieser beitag ist ein persönlicher
triumph für sebastian kurz riesenjubel
bei der svp für den alten und wohl auch
neuen bundeskanzler sind als
bundesregierung im mai abgewählt worden
es waren schwere vier monate und heute
hat uns die bevölkerung zurück gewählt
vielen vielen dank
kurz wir jetzt auf alle parteien im
parlament zu gehen doch die sondierung
wird schwierig so ist die lage laut orf
hochrechnung die svp bekommt 37,1
prozent plus 5,7 die sozialdemokraten
fallen auf 21,7 prozent die fdp stürzt
um 9,9 prozent ab auf 16,1 steilen
zugewinne für die grünen jetzt 14
prozent die liberalen neos bekommen 7,8
die anderen 3,3 prozent trübe stimmung
deshalb bei den freiheitlichen tapfer
hatten fc anhänger für die
fernsehkameras die verluste weg
geklatscht ibiza affäre und der jüngste
spesenskandal bedeuten jetzt wohl
opposition
es ist natürlich das wahlergebnis kein
auftrag zu einem progressiven eintritt
in koalitionsgespräche das muss man
schon auch klar sehen und daher bereiten
wir uns damit vor die partei neu
aufzustellen
enttäuschung auch bei den
sozialdemokraten sie stellte
jahrzehntelang den kanzler in österreich
jetzt für die spitzenkandidatin pamela
rendi-wagner das schlechteste ergebnis
der spd nach dem krieg ein sieg an den
sturz von kurz nicht in einen sieg
verwandeln dennoch wie sie die partei
weiter führen
ich denke der wahlkampf vor der richtige
und es ist nicht so dass man
verantwortung an zum einen schlechten
zeiten übernimmt und sie dann auch
gleich wieder abgibt weil die zeit
wieder schlecht ist das ist nicht meine
riesen jubel dagegen um grünen-chef
kugler die klimadebatte sorgte für das
größte politische comeback in österreich
nach dem krieg vor zwei jahren aus dem
parlament geflogen jetzt womöglich sogar
kandidat für regierungsbeteiligung eine
koalition mit kurz führte jedoch
schwierig vor allem wegen der klima und
migrationspolitik
ich werde die server das gespräch suchen
opfer handlungen überhaupt einen sinn
haben
das ist aber eine vorstufe und so wie es
jetzt ausschaut nicht so treiben die
grüne den preis hoch für etwaige
koalitionsgespräche
und auch mit der spd wird es schwierig
die tiefe abneigung zwischen rendi
wagner und kurz war bei den war debatten
offensichtlich für codes geht es jetzt
um die zukunft müsste jetzt schon seiner
sicht wohl fünf jahre mal durchregieren
denn selbst für ihn den großen
wahlsieger ist es natürlich schwierig da
es das dritte mal in vorgezogene
neuwahlen zu gehen kurz kommunikation im
wahlkampf hoch professionell seine
themen innere sicherheit und migration
haben gezogen eine debatte um die
wahlkampffinanzierung der svp hat ihm
nicht geschadet
für den alten und wohl auch neuen
bundeskanzlers ist das in österreich
gibt es heute abend torte die stärkung
kann er für die koalitionsverhandlungen
gut gebrauchen
und wir erreichen den wahlgewinner in
der hofburg in wien einen schönen guten
abend schön guten abend nach deutschland
sie bräuchten nach diesem grandiosen
wahlergebnis die fpö nicht mehr und
trotzdem schließen sie heute abend auch
eine koalition mit den rechtsnationalen
nicht aus nach allem was geschehen ist
warum nicht schauen sie die inhaltliche
zusammenarbeit mit der freiheitlichen
partei die hat in den letzten beiden
jahren sehr gut funktioniert wir haben
sehr viel weitergebracht und die
zustimmung für diese regierung war
extrem hoch
es gab danach das ibiza video und die
neuwahl die kein wunsch sondern eine
notwendigkeit war und danach haben uns
die sozialdemokratie und die
freiheitliche partei gemeinsam als
bundesregierung abgewählt und mich im
parlament abgewählt das erste mal in der
geschichte jetzt vier monate später hat
die bevölkerung uns zurück gewählt mit
einem noch nie dagewesenen erfolg wir
haben als volkspartei fast so viele
stimmen wie die sozialdemokratie und die
freiheitliche partei zusammen
wir haben den historisch besten erfolg
aller zeiten für unsere volkspartei und
insofern werde ich auch genau das tun
was ich meinen wählerinnen und wählern
im wahlkampf versprochen habe nämlich
wenn wir gewählt werden mit 1 gespräche
zu führen und versuchen eine
bestmögliche koalition für österreich
auf die beine zu stellen nun haben hat
man deutlich gemerkt wie sie versucht
haben die geschichte mit ibiza und so
weiter als eine kleine blessur in einer
in der sache doch erfreulichen
zusammenarbeit darzustellen aber es hat
er mit ivica nicht aufgehört die
skandale ging danach immer weiter
und selbst der fpö-generalsekretär sagt
heute das wahlergebnis ist für uns die
fpö ganz gewiss kein auftrag zum weiter
mitregieren wäre jetzt nicht von ihnen
klare ansage genau das richtige also ja
vielleicht würden sie besser wissen was
ich tun sollte er sich das selbst weiß
ich habe mich immer daran gehalten nicht
zu schnell meine meinung zu ändern
sondern einfach das zu tun was ich
vorher auch versprochen habe und ich
habe vor der wahl
ein versprechen abgegeben nämlich dass
ich mit allen parteien gespräche führen
werde dass sich unvoreingenommen in all
diese gespräche hinein gehen werde und
dass ich versuchen werde mit allen
parteien eine schnittmenge zu finden
das gilt für die freiheitlichen das gilt
für die sozialdemokraten das gilt für
die grünen und das gilt für die neos das
sind die vier anderen parteien die im
parlament vertreten sind wir haben das
beste ergebnis eingefahren dass man sich
nur wünschen kann
wir sind gestärkt worden wir haben einen
erfolg den ich fast noch immer nicht
ganz verdaut kann weil er für mich in
dem ausmaß einfach nicht einmal in
meinen träumen real war
und insofern geben sie uns doch die
möglichkeit einmal dieses gute
wahlergebnis in aller dankbarkeit
anzunehmen vor allem aber auch
respektvoll mit dem ergebnis umzugehen
und respektvoll mit dem ergebnis
umzugehen heißt aus meiner sicht nach
der wahl das zu tun was man vor der wahl
versprochen hat und das ist mit allen zu
sprechen
nun haben sie große kraft gewonnen heute
ganz zweifellos erlauben sie da einem
ausländischen reporter die wichtigste
ausländische frage sie wissen dass die
deutsche regierung die benelux
regierungen die frankreich regierung und
so weiter sehr darauf hoffen dass die
allianz mit den zweifelhaften
rechtsnationalen in österreich aufhört
spielt ein solcher gesichtspunkt bei den
überlegungen die sie jetzt anstellen
werden überhaupt eine rolle
nein ich bin meinen wählerinnen und
wählern verpflichtet und nicht im
ausland und auch nicht irgendwelchen
medienvertretern und auch anderen
tippgebern ich war gerade in einer
fernsehdiskussion er hat ausgerechnet
der chef der partei die aus dem
parlament hinausgeflogen ist mir noch
tipps mitgegeben
wie wir jetzt die regierungsarbeit
anlegen sollen oder mit wem wir regieren
sollen ich kann ihnen nur sagen ich
stehe zu meinem wort und mein wort im
wahlkampf war
wir sprechen mit einem parlament
vertretenen parteien das werden wir tun
und ich werde dann versuchen abzuwägen
mit welcher partei gibt es die größten
inhaltlichen übereinstimmungen mit
welcher partei ist auch die notwendige
stabilität vorhanden um eine regierung
bilden zu können
mit welcher partei finden wir auch
personen die die charakter
die eigenschaften haben die es braucht
um ein regierungsamt auszuüben
und all das gilt es dann abzuwägen und
zu beraten
sie müssen sich vorstellen wir haben
heute als volkspartei einen historischen
tag erlebt und ich könnte jetzt
natürlich mich ausgelassen freuen das
werde ich heute hoffentlich nach dem
interview auch noch tun können aber
neben dieser unendlich großen freude die
ich empfinde und der unendlich großen
dankbarkeit und spüre ich schon eine
starke verantwortung das ist ja keine
kleinigkeit eine regierung zu bilden
das ist eine sehr verantwortungsvolle
aufgabe da geht es um die zukunft
unseres landes um die nächsten fünf
jahre unseres landes und das gilt es
ganz behutsam und ordentlich zu machen
und dafür werde ich mich auch die
entsprechende zeit nehmen und mich jetzt
sicherlich nicht zu schnellschüssen
hinreißen lassen
irgendwelche parteien ausschließen
irgendwelche parteien präferieren weil
das vielleicht das ausland oder
irgendein medium sich wünschen würde
das waren trauen sie ihnen bekommen
haben ist lang reicht ja einige
beerdigung geht es auch
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen
wann wir eine gewählte regierung haben
das kann ich ihnen noch nicht zu 100
prozent prophezeit es wird sicherlich
eine gewisse zeit brauchen diese
regierungsbildung zu bewältigen ich
werde wahrscheinlich diese woche den
regierungsbildungsauftrag bekommen werde
mich dann sofort an die gespräche machen
letztes mal waren wir sehr sehr schnell
ich kann mir aber durchaus vorstellen
dass das diesmal deutlich länger dauert
insbesondere weil die situation in den
einzelnen parteien sehr unübersichtlich
ist in der freiheitlichen partei gab so
eine massive niederlage
dass die von sich aus sagen sie wollen
wahrscheinlich gar nicht regieren in der
sozialdemokratie das schlechteste
ergebnis in der geschichte wird auch
noch diskussionen in den nächsten tagen
und wochen geben die grünen sind neu ins
parlament gekommen und der chef der
grünen hat mir gesagt das ist jetzt
einmal seine hauptverantwortung
überhaupt diesen club zu konstituieren
insofern werden wir aber vor allem auch
die anderen parteien glaube ich durchaus
ein stück wird zeit brauchen für diese
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
da ist es sehr gut dass die österreicher
mit der gegenwärtig regierenden
expertenregierung ohne politische
parteien zufrieden sind
wünschen ihnen einen schönen abend und
danken für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
vielen dank für die möglichkeit im
angebot von heute de finden sie zu
diesem wahlergebnis unter anderem eine
analyse im gespräch mit klartext von
österreichs bekanntesten analytiker für
politik nun folgen hier nachrichten von
gundula gause in thüringen wirft ein
zweiter untersuchungsausschuss zum
terrornetzwerk des rechtsextremen nsu
den behörden massive fehler vor
in dem abschlussbericht der morgen
vorgelegt wird heißt es vor allem die
zusammenarbeit der thüringer
sicherheitsbehörden auch mit dem bund
sei ungenügend gewesen
vorliegende informationen seien nicht
zusammengeführt und fakten falsch
bewertet worden
bis 2011 hatte die rechtsextreme
terrorgruppe nsu zahlreiche straftaten
begangen und bundesweit zehn menschen
getötet
bei neuen protesten gegen die
chinesische regierung ist es in hongkong
zu schweren zusammenstößen zwischen
polizei und demonstranten gekommen
einsatzkräfte gingen mit tränengas und
pfefferspray gegen aktivisten vor
die brandsätze und steine geworfen
hatten es war eine der heftigsten
auseinandersetzungen seit beginn der
proteste seitdem wurden mehr als 1500
menschen festgenommen
in moskau hat die russische opposition
ihre proteste vom sommer fortgesetzt
etwa 25.000 menschen gingen auf die
straßen und forderten inhaftierte
demonstranten freizulassen
auch kreml-kritiker navalny nahm an der
kundgebung teil
schon im juli und august hatten
zehntausende für freie und faire
kommunalwahlen demonstriert dabei waren
tausende demonstranten vorübergehend
festgenommen worden
einige wurden auch zu hohen
gefängnisstrafen verurteilt
us-präsident trump ist in der debatte um
ein mögliches amtsenthebungsverfahren
mit einer videobotschaft in die
gegenoffensive gegangen
die ukraine affäre und das vorgehen der
opposition sei so wörtlich der größte
betrug in der geschichte der
amerikanischen politik die demokraten
versuchten ihn zu stoppen und den us
bürgern ihre freiheit zu nehmen
die partei um parlamentssprecherin
closen bereitet ein verfahren gegen junk
vor weil er die ukraine zu ermittlungen
gegen den präsidentschaftsbewerber der
demokraten biden und dessen sohn
gedrängt haben soll
30 jahre seit dem fall der berliner
mauer das müsste selbstverständlich
grund zum feiern sein entsprechende
veranstaltungen sind auch terminiert
aber die passende stimmung dafür stellt
sich nicht so recht ein
dafür ist bei den ereignissen und bei
den wahlergebnissen der letzten zeit
zwischen deutschland ost und deutschland
west das trennende zu sehr im
vordergrund gestanden
was viele im westen die sich mit der
vereinigung nicht wirklich vertieft
befassen wollen schlicht für groben
undank halten ist für viele im osten
eine erinnerung an demütigung und
bevormundung die mit weg wachsendem
abstand auch nicht von alleine besser
wurde aus gegebenem anlass seine
stimmungs studie ost west von andreas
weiß sicher ist wassertiere was damals
kurz nach der maueröffnung für aufregung
und viele lacher sorgte doch zonen gaby
mit der vermeintlichen banane
da schwang auch viel wahres mit der
blick auf den teil deutschlands der
vielen im westen bis heute fremd ist
im ddr museum in berlin treffen wir ilko
sascha kowalczuk der historiker
beschreibt in seinem buch die übernahme
die sich der ostdeutschen die ja im märz
90 noch die schnelle einheit gewählt
hatten das ergebnis aber haben sich
wieder anders vorgestellt vom osten
blieb nichts übrig im großen teil muss
man auch sagen gott sei dank aber
das war es dann auch mit den menschen
gemacht wurde das ist zum teil sehr
katastrophal gewesen und hat im zuge im
hohen maße einer übernahme anpassung war
der begriff den man in den 19 jahren
überall hörte und am ende des tages
stand hinter anpassung dass die dass die
bundesrepublik die bundesdeutsche eliten
erwarteten von den ostdeutschen dass sie
so werden wie sie glaubten dass sie
selbst sind die freude über die einheit
war groß doch die die aus dem westen
kamen um dem osten zu helfen teil der
bundesrepublik zu werden wie sie es oft
an fingerspitzengefühl mangeln
und dass nicht die erwartung am besten
sein kann dass sich der ostdeutsche am
westdeutschen kulturell nullmeridian
orientieren orientieren müsste sondern
dass es eben teil unserer deutschen
identität ist dass wir sehr
unterschiedlich sind dass wir sehr
heterogen sind
das muss man im westen akzeptieren so
wie man im osten eben auch verstehen
muss das natürlich im westen große
anstrengungen verbracht wurden
um auch die deutsche einheit zu
finanzieren es flossen millionen für den
aufbau ost wirtschaftlich eine große
belastung trotzdem gingen viele aus dem
osten in den westen hinterließen in der
alten heimat gewaltige lücken in
führungspositionen hat es allerdings
kaum jemand geschafft
marieke reimann chefredakteurin von z
dem jugendportal derzeit die rostockerin
ist einer der ganz wenigen aus dem osten
in einer spitzenposition
wer sitzt in den führungsetagen egal ob
das jetzt reichweiten und auflagenstarke
medien sind oder ob das landesparlamente
sind es geht einfach nicht dass das nach
30 jahren mauerfall einfach so
verheerend westdeutsch hauptsächlich
männliche hauptsächlich weiß ist und es
fehle an vorbildern so die 32-jährige
es gibt einfach mein name noch zu wenig
menschen die explizit sagen ich komme
aus dem osten die auch eine gewisse
gesellschaftliche reichweite haben und
gesagt um zeigen zu sagen schau mal ich
bin aus dem gleichen verhältnissen
gekommen wie du hat weiß ich plattenbau
wenig geld gehabt und dann vielleicht
auch nicht ganz so bildungsnahe wie
manch andere am besten keine akademiker
als eltern sondern arbeiter hintergrund
und trotzdem bin ich jetzt auf der
position und habe das und das erreicht
30 jahre nach dem jubel über revolution
und mauerfall der weg vom ihr zum wir
zwischen ost und west ist länger als
gedacht
in europa wird zu wenig über den krieg
in syrien nachgedacht man glaubt sich
das leisten zu können bei der strom der
flüchtlinge vor allem durch den vertrag
mit der türkei einigermaßen gebremst
scheint weil es keine hoffnung auf
besserung gibt und der diktatorisch
regierende assad sich durchzusetzen
scheint in den meisten gebieten
jedenfalls aber einen so blutigen
konflikt in europas unmittelbarer
nachbarschaft zu geben ignorieren ist
keine option
die scheinbare ruhe ist ganz wesentlich
das werk von us verbündeten iran und
russland unsere moskau korrespondentin
für begann war mit russischen militär an
den brennpunkten in idlib und aleppo
solches geleit beschränkt natürlich die
möglichkeiten einer reporterin aber sie
war dort hat selbst gesehen und ist
zurück aus der region um chan scheichun
drei tage waren sie auf der flucht
erzählen sie aus idlib die letzte große
rebellenhochburg des syrien krieges
liegt nur wenige kilometer von hier
entfernt
es ist grauenhaft dort menschen
verschwinden und kehren nicht zurück
mein sohn war plötzlich weg tage lang
konnten wir ihn nicht finden
die terroristen entführen unsere männer
und söhne um uns zu zwingen zu bleiben
100.000 lehrer habe ich bezahlt damit
sie uns gehen lassen
wer kein geld hat dem wird der schmuck
abgenommen alles was irgendwie wertvoll
sein könnte in gepanzerten fahrzeugen
hat das russische militär uns gemeinsam
mit anderen journalisten in die gegend
um han ji hoon gebracht bis ende august
hatte ich hier ein al qaida ableger das
sagen nach wochenlangen kämpfen hat die
syrische armee mit russischer
unterstützung die kontrolle erlangt nun
sei die stadt bereit für rückkehrer sagt
man uns samba dadaab vor dem krieg
lebten hier 60.000 einwohner
die menschen kehren langsam zurück
nachdem das gebiet von minen und anderen
sprengsätzen befreit wurde
etwa sieben bis 800 familien sind schon
zurückgekehrt
sie finden sich inmitten zerstörte
wohnhäuser zertrümmerter infrastruktur
wieder
der wiederaufbau wird lange dauern in
der gegend um handschuhen kamen
chemische waffen zum einsatz zuletzt im
mai dieses jahres
viele länder darunter amerika und
deutschland machen us truppen für den
einsatz von chemiewaffen gegen die
eigene bevölkerung verantwortlich
die syrische armee will uns von einer
anderen version überzeugen
sie führen uns durch höhlensysteme die
bis vor kurzem tausenden islamistischen
kämpfern als unterschlupf gedient haben
sollen
in all dem staub liegt vielleicht etwas
zufällig eine jacke der weiße helme der
organisation die 2016 den alternativen
nobelpreis erhielt für die rettung
zehntausender syrischen zivilisten
es scheine der säuberung der
tunnelsysteme wurden materialien für die
herstellung von chemischen waffen
gefunden
an diesem ort saßen die weisheit sie
haben die nutzung von chemiewaffen durch
die syrische armee gegen die
zivilbevölkerung inszeniert der kampf um
die öffentliche meinung ist einer der
schauplätze des syrien krieges unter den
augen der militärs hören wir in
handschuhen von hoffnung und sieht mit
gottes hilfe werden wir in syrien wieder
so leben wie früher und wir werden den
dreckskerl auf die köpfe treten die es
auf unser land abgesehen haben
syrien wird noch stärker als früher sein
volk und seine armee wir verlassen van
schaik runden
wenige stunden später gibt es meldungen
über tel aviv vorjahr und raketen die
aus der gegend abgefeuert wurden
die pro assad truppen haben idlib ins
visier genommen
im blick der sich gelohnt hat und der
sonntag war ein voller tag im sport
zunächst sie zwei ergebnisse der
sonntagsspiele in der fußball bundesliga
verlor am abend der erste fc köln gegen
hertha bsc berlin deutlich mit 0 zu 4
zuvor unterlag fortuna düsseldorf
ebenfalls zu hause dem sc freiburg mit 1
zu 2 die breisgauer damit überraschend
auf rang drei der tabelle
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton hat
den großen preis von russland gewonnen
der mercedes pilot setzte sich in
sotschi vor seinen teamkollegen weitere
potters durch dritter wurde
ferrari-pilot fahren erklärt
sebastian vettel lag eine woche nach
seinem ersten saisonsieg in singapur
lange zeit in führung schied dann aber
wegen technischer probleme aus einen
überraschenden erfolg erzielte die
deutsche kanutin andrea herzog bei den
kanu slalom weltmeisterschaften im
norden spaniens
die ersten 19 jahre alte newcomerin aus
leipzig gewann sensationell gold im
canadier einer
es war die einzige medaille für den
deutschen kanu-verband den berlin
marathon hat der äthiopier kenenisa
bekele gewonnen und dabei einen neuen
weltrekord denkbar knapp verpasst
bekäme brauchte für die knapp 42
kilometer zwei stunden eine minute und
41 sekunden und blieb damit nur zwei
sekunden über der im vorjahr am gleichen
ort aufgestellten bestmarke des
kenianers eliud kipchoge die
deutschstunde kommt als film ins kino
siegfried lenz welterfolg war ein
schlüssel der den blick in die zeit der
nazidiktatur in einer erzählung öffnete
dieses buch wurde gebraucht es erschien
1968 als der hunger nach verstehen
ermessen und einblick in den schrecken
der nazi-zeit gerade erwarte die
deutschstunde wurde pflichtlektüre in
schulen
es ist eine geschichte darüber wie die
kraken arme des nazi-regimes in die
fernsten ecken des landes reichen leben
und beziehungen zerstörten längst hatte
beim schreiben das schicksal des malers
emil nolde vor augen der als opfer und
gegner der nazis galt heute weiß man
dass das vorbild schlecht gewählt war
neue war ein antisemit den nazis näher
als die ihm glauben wollten
für manche ist lenz deutschstunde damit
entwertet von christian schwochow nicht
der so erfolgreiche regisseur glaubt
unbeirrt an den kern von lenz geschichte
und um die geht es nicht um die von
noldes woche setzt sie so kraftvoll ins
bild wie er es kann und das heißt
verdammt gut sagt und zeigt claudio
armbruster
es geht um menschlichkeit und
freundschaft zerbricht weil der eine die
so genannte pflicht über alles stellt
und den anderen verrät den hast du
gleich zu lesen 1944 irgendwo an der
deutschen nordseeküste malverbot für den
maler entartete kunst
das verbot ist beschlossen und
ausgesprochen aber noch in der
hauptstadt
mich haben sie beauftragt das neue
verbot zu überwachen
und es geht um den jungen der zwischen
zwei vaterfiguren steht der versucht es
beiden recht zu machen und dabei
zwischen die fronten gerät wollen wir
zusammen malen darf sie aber niemanden
verraten
hat er gearbeitet ich habe mich gefragt
hätte gemalt
die verfilmung der deutschstunde von
siegfried lenz drehbuch und regie heide
und christian schwochow mutter und sohn
für mich ist die landschaft eigentlich
wiener hauptfiguren der geschichte ich
wollte eigentlich dass es sich wie das
ende der welt anführt dass es wie eine
apokalyptische mondlandschaft fast wirkt
wie man sagt hier seid ihr doch nur
unter euch warum führt ihr diesen krieg
der ganz woanders seine schlachtfelder
hat denn hier weiter wo es doch nur euch
gibt es wohnt doch dort niemand ist das
beobachtet euch doch kaum einer wie im
roman wird die geschichte aus der sicht
des jungen erzählt sie die jahre später
seine erinnerungen an die pflicht und
die wahrheit bildgewalt kaum musik
siegfried lenz hat sich bei der figur
des malers vom leben und der kunst emil
noldes inspirieren lassen nolde
inszenierte sich als opfer des regimes
war aber selbst antisemit und stand den
nazis
das ist heute bekannt auch lance wusste
von 0 des nationalsozialistischen
verstrickungen nahm diese aber nicht in
den roman mit auf das ist die freiheit
der kunst so sehen es auch die
filmemacher das war eine bewusste
entscheidung dass wir nicht über eine
historische figur einen film machen
wollten
natürlich kommen jetzt die fragen aber
das ist eine debatte die muss parallel
ausgeführt werden und wie finde es gut
dass man bis der film einen teil dazu
beitragen kann weil unsere haltung ist
da wirklich klar
der film lässt einen nicht mehr los
wegen dieser geschichte von anpassung
und widerstand die bis heute ihre
bedeutung nicht verloren hat und wegen
der bildsprache die stärker kaum sein
könnte
[Applaus]
der kinostart am donnerstag wird ein
termin der nächsten woche dalian tag hat
mehr muster feststellungsklage im diesel
skandal vor dem oberlandesgericht
braunschweig beginnt am montag ein
großes gerichtsverfahren gegen vw
festgestellt werden soll ob der
autobauer seine kunden geschädigt hat
geklagt haben der bundesverband der
verbraucherzentrale und der adac hinter
der sammelklage stinkt dampf 449.000
diesel kunden im europaparlament stehen
ab montag die nominierten kommissare
rede und antwort jeweils drei stunden
werden sie von den zuständigen
ausschüssen gelöchert sind sie geeignet
oder nicht vorläufig blockiert rumäniens
und ungarns kandidaten propagandaschau
und säbelrasseln am dienstag feiert die
volksrepublik china ihren siebzigsten
geburtstag und erinnert an ihren enormen
wirtschaftlichen aufstieg chinas
probleme heute der handelskrieg mit den
usa die menschenrechtslage und die
proteste in hongkong kunststoff statt
kunstschnee kopenhagen eröffnet am
freitag seine erste skipiste und das auf
dem dach einer müllverbrennungsanlage
450 meter lang ist der zauberteppich aus
plastik optisch noch ein wenig
gewöhnungsbedürftig und das wetter in
der neuen woche wird wechselhaft und
windig kurz der herbst kommt morgen muss
im norden bei wechselnder bewölkung mit
regen gerechnet werden
nach süden hin wird es freundlicher bei
zum teil stürmischen wind sind im osten
und im bergland orkanartige böen möglich
14 bis 20 grad
am dienstag ist es im südosten noch mal
sonnig und warm im norden gibt es
dauerregen ab wochenmitte wird es
überall wechselhaft und kühler weiß auch
nicht was ich sagen soll es droht oder
es verspricht eine interessante woche zu
werden zu hause in europa in syrien
österreich nicht zuletzt in washington
die redaktion behält das alles im auge
und am abend sind marietta slomka und
heinz wolf dann für sie hier alles gute
bis bald genannt
[Musik]